in contrast to prokaryotic transcription
eukaryotic transcription is pretty
different because in eukaryotes while
the mRNA is transcribing while the mRNA
is transcribed at the same time there
are several modifications enzymes like
splicing enzymes and capping enzyme
which is acting upon the mRNA and it
needs two modification of the ends of
the mRNA m7g cap and a poly a tail now
in this video we'll talk about the
capping process at the five prime end of
the eukaryotic mRNA first part of the
video will focus on the mechanism of the
five prime capping and at the end of
this video will focus on the
significance of the five prime
capping in what are the physiological
aspects and what are the importance of
the five prime capping so this is the
structure of the m7g cap which is like a
one-in cap which is methylated at the
seventh residue we all know that in
eukaryotes the you transcription takes
place inside the nucleus so let's just
dive right in the nucleus to understand
the process better the RNA polymerase
move from a 5 prime to 3 prime direction
and the mRNA which is transcribed is
hanging out from the RNA polymerase now
there are several modification enzymes
like 2 splicing enzymes like capping
enzymes which sits on the phosphorylated
c-terminal domain of the RNA polymerase
now these capping enzymes turns out to
be very important in terms of modifying
the 5 prime end so they act on the 5
prime end now the capping enzyme is a
complex of three different enzymes first
the methyl transferase the tri
phosphatase and the guanylyltransferase
all these enzymes are important to make
the 5 prime cap so we'll look at the
process of capping in a step-by-step
manner so the first step is to take the
5 prime
end of the growing mRNA proxy proximal
to the region with the capping complex
is sitting and that happens by a DNA
curling in mechanism then first enzyme
to act upon the five prime end of the
growing RNA is that tri phosphatase
which chops off one phosphate group then
guanylyltransferase acts on the end and
it transfer the guanine to the end of
the RNA at the five prime end now the
last enzyme the methyl transferase
transfers a five methyl group at the
seventh position of the guanine so this
is the process of formation of the m7g
cap now we should try to understand what
is the significance of this capping
process it turns out the m7g cap
protects RNA from any kind of nucleus
attack mostly then eggs or nucleus
attack now m7g cap also interacts with
the eukaryotic translation initiation
factors like initiation factor for en
for G which in turns
coordinate with polyadenylation binding
protein to hold the mRNA in a circular
from such that several ribosomes can
translate the mRNA simultaneously and
enhance the rate of translation so this
capping process has important role in
terms of translation as well now m7g cap
helps the nuclear export of the RNA mRNA
because it is the m7g cap which
interacts with tricks SR or eg say
proteins protein complex and then all of
these complex directed towards the
exporting and that helps the mRNA to be
exported out into the cytoplasm and in
the cytoplasm when it is exported out it
can sit on the ribosomes and it could be
translated
now this capping process is very well
understood by the virus they understand
this basic and fundamental host
machinery to use their for their own
welfare it turns out the player nasty
trick called cap snatching now influenza
virus is a negative stranded RNA virus
so it's inject in genetic material which
is a negative strand and RNA but it is
not detected by the host ribosomes
because host ribosome cannot detect a
negative strand RNA right and it cannot
be transcribed at that format so it has
to convert it into positive strand RNA
but still there is a problem these
positive strand RNA don't have the cap
and in case of eukaryote the cap is
important for translated translation
right so it somehow has to acquire the
cap and it turns out several proteins
which are associated with the viral
polymerase help to cleave some portion
of the host cap and put it on the viral
mRNA and now when it is exported into
the cytoplasm it can sit on the ribosome
just like a host RNA and it can be
translated that's how RNA virus
understand the fundamental mechanism and
hijack it in for their own survival so
these are the whole concept about the
five prime capping and I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe and do let
me know how you liked my video in the
comments thank you